[Music]
the use of leather as an artist medium
dates back to the Middle Ages when it
was crafted into fierce animal shapes
that were then affixed to battle helmets
fast-forward several centuries and some
artists are rediscovering leather as a
sculpting material and redefining the
art of sculpture this is leather
reimagined in this studio cowhides
become art instead of a sofa or of their
shoes its artistry over utility the
artist starts by developing a pattern he
draws imagery within a paper fishing it
represents the life cycle of a rainbow
trout he places the pattern on a cowhide
and using a scriber he lightly etches
the fish shape into the leather using a
razor blade he follows the etched lines
to cut out the fish shape
[Music]
he dampens the entire piece with the wet
cloth this softens the leather to
prepare it for the drawings on the
pattern which will be transferred to it
he places the pattern on the dampened
leather double using a round tip tool he
traces the drawings the tool makes light
impressions on the supple leather
following those lines with the swivel
knife he carves the imagery into the
leather when the leather starts to dry
Jiri dampens it then with the wedge tool
analogy he depresses the leather around
the main artwork this raises the images
above the background he hammers a disc
tip tool into the leather to make a
fisheye indentation then using an actual
stone he lightly pounds the rocks in the
image this transfers the stones texture
to the leather he also uses the rock to
create shading on the trout and the
foliage for the fish-scale detail he
pounds a tool with a crescent-shaped tip
into the leather
he works in a linear fashion row on row
to punch tight scales across much of the
art this creates a textural symmetry
throughout the piece turning to a second
matching fish shape he shaves leather
from the back of the fence to give them
a lighter more realistic look he applies
glue to the edges this plain fish shape
will serve as the back of the sculpture
he applies more fins to the glute areas
in the under belly of the fish art he
then brings the two sides of the fish
together and close them leaving the
bottom fins and the mouth open using an
industrial sewing machine for leather he
stitches the fish together with heavy
nylon thread this fish art is now ready
to go from flat to 3d he stuffs
polyester fill into it the leather has
been moistened again so that when it
dries it will shrink tight to the
filling as he stuffs the leather he uses
a wooden rod to distribute the filling
he then clues a carved leather fish mask
onto the face
this adds drama to the piece he trims
the mask then he applies a rainbow of
color to the trout beginning with the
silvery shade of white he paints an
olive-green shade on the top of the fish
sculpture and a pinkish red hue in the
middle this reflects the colors of the
rainbow trout
he dabs black paint on the fish
sculpture to replicate the spots
normally found on trout he then marks
the fish sculpture extensively with
silvery white speckles
[Music]
he defines some of the etched lines with
the same paint to make the imagery
bolder the artist signs the leather fish
making the entire leather sculpture
takes over a month now it's ready for
public viewing
[Music]